well here we are in the Indian Ocean a
very remote part indeed of the Indian
Ocean we are 35 meters down that it's
four hundred and forty two feet taking
the view I guess in the next hour we'll
explore an area of the ocean which is
uncharted undiscovered unknown just
above the Twilight Zone beneath us
off the coral atoll of Aldabra it is a
mission to discover new species to find
new life and to see if man's impact
stretches to this pristine and protected
part of the world
well it is science it is exploration it
is adventure all combined and has never
been done before
on a live television program this is a
world first algebra is famous for its
remoteness and for its very treacherous
currents
anything could happen so don't go
anywhere sit back enjoy the viewers like
we are and let us take you down to the
depths very cozy in here getting warmer
by the minute I have to say and one
person that I'm already very well
acquainted with is my pilot for this
mission Randy holt thank you so much for
having us and well what an extraordinary
working environment you have it's
amazing down here you know every dive is
different and we get to go places where
people have never been before explain
where we are to change the cameras which
I can do we've tucked herself into a
crevice ifferent 135 meters yeah we're
kind of leaning against the edge of a
cliff an underwater cliff
we were fighting some down there at some
some updrafts when we got to this
position so we just kind of perked
ourselves on a ledge and are trying to
stay stationary and I should give you a
proper title of course you are an
Aquanaut if an astronaut explores space
you explore the deep
yes you know where an inner space it's a
whole new place down here and you know
it's a 3d environment so we're always
moving around
where we are how how we're moving
through the water column are we lighter
are we done the heavier all that yes
exactly it's it's it's amazing to what
should be all the controls and as you
said you're flying these submersibles
you're not driving them and as you said
the oceans make up 97% of the habitable
space on planet Earth which gives you
both a sense of the depth of the oceans
but also that 3d environment that Randy
was talking about we have joined an
expedition led by the scientist of the
natural mission their aim is to perform
a deep ocean health check to map to
chart to sample to see perhaps what no
one has ever seen before and even search
for those rarely-seen species lurking in
the shadows the dream perhaps of a
sixgill shark or even a Celia camp the
Dino fish thought to be extinct for
millions of years and crucially to see
what is happening to that often colorful
coral as it faces unprecedented threats
it is so important as habitat and home
to millions of species the big question
for the scientists is could the deeper
ocean be a refuge from the dangers of
climate change and even from plastic
pollution that we've talked so much
about at sky well we are not alone down
here this is someone the red one
although it's been a showered by this
downdraft of sediment which you will
hear the team referred to as Omega out
there we can see them is sub to the
yellow at the yellow one other yes the
yellow one well we had the red one I've
already drawn at which they called
Kensington